Kevin: Guten Morgen alle zusammen. Heute geht es um die Analyse von Kundenreklamationen.
Markus: Ja, guten Morgen. Also, ähm, ich habe einige Berichte durchgesehen und...
Sandra: Entschuldigung, ich bin kurz spät dran. Können wir nochmal von vorne anfangen?
Kevin: Kein Problem, Sandra. Also, ich wollte sagen, dass wir eine Zunahme an Reklamationen bei den Türgriffabdeckungen haben.
Markus: Genau. Die häufigsten Beschwerden betreffen die Lackierung und die Passgenauigkeit.
Sandra: Ja, das habe ich auch bemerkt. Besonders das Modell XZ-101 scheint oft betroffen zu sein.
Thomas: Ich denke, wir sollten auch die Lieferanten überprüfen. Möglicherweise liegt das Problem bei den Materialien.
Markus: Noch nicht wirklich. Es könnte an einer Änderung im Produktionsprozess liegen, aber wir müssen das noch genauer untersuchen.
Kevin: Ok, also, was denkst du, sollten unsere nächsten Schritte sein?
Sandra: Wir sollten zunächst die betroffenen Produktionschargen identifizieren und überprüfen, ob es da Unterschiede gibt.
Thomas: Klingt vernünftig. Und was ist mit den Materialien? Könnte da ein Problem sein?
Markus: Ja, das könnte auch sein. Ich werde das Materialteam bitten, die letzten Lieferungen zu überprüfen.
Kevin: Gut. Und wir sollten auch die Reklamationsdaten auswerten, um Muster zu erkennen.
Sandra: Ja, definitiv. Wir sollten uns die Zeiträume ansehen und vielleicht auch geografische Unterschiede.
Thomas: Ja, gute Idee. Ich werde die Datenbank nach diesen Kriterien durchsuchen.
Sandra: Super. Und, äh, wir sollten auch mit dem Vertrieb sprechen, um zu sehen, ob sie Feedback von Kunden haben.
Kevin: Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Vielleicht haben sie zusätzliche Informationen, die uns weiterhelfen.
Markus: Genau. Also, ich denke, wir haben einen Plan.
Kevin: Ja, das klingt gut. Ich werde gleich mit der Datenanalyse beginnen und dich auf dem Laufenden halten.
Sandra: Perfekt. Dann, äh, bis später.
Kevin: Bis später.
Anna: Entschuldigung, ich bin jetzt auch dazugekommen. Was habe ich verpasst?
Kevin: Oh, hallo Anna. Wir haben gerade über die Zunahme an Reklamationen bei den Türgriffabdeckungen gesprochen und was unsere nächsten Schritte sein sollten.
Anna: Verstanden. Habt ihr schon über die Qualitätskontrollen gesprochen?
Markus: Noch nicht im Detail. Hast du da irgendwelche Anmerkungen?
Anna: Ja, ich denke, wir sollten die Kontrollen intensivieren, besonders bei den betroffenen Modellen.
Sandra: Das klingt nach einem guten Plan. Wir könnten zusätzliche Stichproben nehmen und detaillierter prüfen.
Thomas: Ich stimme zu. Vielleicht sollten wir auch die Prüfprotokolle der letzten Monate durchsehen.
Kevin: Ja, und nicht zu vergessen, wir müssen auch das Feedback der Kundenservice-Mitarbeiter berücksichtigen.
Anna: Absolut. Ich werde die Daten aus den letzten Reklamationen durchgehen und Muster suchen.
Markus: Gut, das klingt nach einem Plan. Wann können wir die ersten Ergebnisse erwarten?
Sandra: Ich denke, wir sollten bis Ende der Woche einige Erkenntnisse haben.
Thomas: In Ordnung. Ich werde mit dem Materialteam sprechen und sehen, was wir über die letzten Lieferungen herausfinden können.
Kevin: Perfekt. Dann sind wir erst mal gut aufgestellt.
Anna: Ok, dann lasst uns dranbleiben und wir sprechen uns in ein paar Tagen wieder.
Kevin: Alles klar. Danke, Leute. Bis dann.
Markus: Bis dann.
Sandra: Tschüss.
Thomas: Tschüss.
Anna: Tschüss.
Kevin: Gut, dann sind wir hier soweit fertig. Aber bevor wir auseinandergehen, möchte ich noch ein paar Punkte klären.
Anna: Sicher, Kevin. Was steht noch auf der Liste?
Kevin: Also, wir müssen auch die Rückläufe aus der jüngsten Kampagne analysieren. Hat jemand dazu schon Daten gesammelt?
Markus: Ja, ich habe da einige Zahlen vorliegen. Die Rücklaufquote war höher als erwartet.
Sandra: Das deckt sich mit dem Feedback, das wir von den Vertriebsmitarbeitern bekommen haben.
Thomas: Das klingt besorgniserregend. Könnte das mit den Qualitätsproblemen zusammenhängen?
Kevin: Sehr wahrscheinlich. Wir sollten das dringend untersuchen und die Ursachen finden.
Anna: Ich werde die Rückläufe in unsere Analyse mit einbeziehen und sehen, ob es Überschneidungen gibt.
Markus: Gut. Ich denke, wir sollten auch die Produktionsdaten genauer unter die Lupe nehmen.
Kevin: Ja, wir müssen alle möglichen Fehlerquellen identifizieren und eliminieren.
Sandra: Ich werde das Produktionsteam informieren und sie bitten, zusätzliche Kontrollen durchzuführen.
Thomas: Und ich werde mit dem Logistikteam sprechen, um sicherzustellen, dass keine Probleme beim Transport aufgetreten sind.
Kevin: Danke, Thomas. Das ist wichtig. Wir müssen wirklich alle Aspekte prüfen.
Anna: Ich werde auch nochmal das Feedback der Kundenservice-Mitarbeiter durchgehen und sehen, ob wir da noch etwas übersehen haben.
Markus: Sehr gut. Ich denke, wir sind auf einem guten Weg. Wir müssen nur konsequent weiterarbeiten.
Kevin: Absolut. Jeder muss seinen Teil beitragen, dann werden wir das Problem lösen können.
Sandra: Dann lassen wir uns keine Zeit verlieren und direkt loslegen.
Thomas: Genau. Je schneller wir handeln, desto besser.
Kevin: Gut, dann sind wir für heute fertig. Danke euch allen für eure Zeit und euren Einsatz.
Anna: Danke, Kevin. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Markus: Ja, bis dann. Tschüss.
Sandra: Tschüss, bis später.
Thomas: Bis dann.
Kevin: Also gut, bevor wir schließen, gibt es noch eine weitere wichtige Sache. Wir haben einige Berichte aus dem letzten Quartal erhalten, die darauf hindeuten, dass es Probleme mit den Lieferzeiten gibt. Wer kann dazu etwas sagen?
Sandra: Das stimmt. Ich habe mit dem Logistikteam gesprochen und es scheint, dass wir einige Engpässe hatten, besonders im Dezember.
Markus: Haben wir herausgefunden, woran das lag? War es ein Problem mit den Lieferanten oder internen Prozessen?
Sandra: Eine Mischung aus beidem, würde ich sagen. Einige Lieferanten hatten Verzögerungen und intern gab es auch ein paar Schwierigkeiten mit der Planung.
Thomas: Vielleicht sollten wir darüber nachdenken, unsere Lieferantenbasis zu diversifizieren, um solche Risiken zu minimieren.
Anna: Das ist ein guter Punkt, Thomas. Und wir könnten auch unsere internen Prozesse straffen. Vielleicht gibt es Möglichkeiten, die Effizienz zu erhöhen.
Kevin: Genau, wir müssen sowohl externe als auch interne Faktoren berücksichtigen. Sandra, kannst du einen Plan erstellen, um diese Probleme anzugehen?
Sandra: Ja, natürlich. Ich werde mich gleich morgen darum kümmern und dann einen Vorschlag ausarbeiten.
Markus: Perfekt. Und wir sollten auch die Kundenzufriedenheit weiterhin im Auge behalten. Wie sind die aktuellen Zahlen?
Thomas: Die letzte Umfrage zeigte einen leichten Rückgang. Wir müssen herausfinden, warum das so ist und Maßnahmen ergreifen, um das zu verbessern.
Anna: Vielleicht könnten wir eine weitere detaillierte Umfrage durchführen, um genauere Einblicke zu bekommen.
Kevin: Gute Idee, Anna. Das sollten wir definitiv machen. Je mehr Daten wir haben, desto besser können wir reagieren.
Sandra: Ich stimme zu. Und wir sollten auch die Kundenservice-Teams schulen, um besser auf Beschwerden reagieren zu können.
Thomas: Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Eine gute Schulung kann viel dazu beitragen, die Kundenzufriedenheit zu erhöhen.
Kevin: Alles klar, dann haben wir einige konkrete Maßnahmen. Sandra, du kümmerst dich um den Plan für die Lieferkettenprobleme. Thomas, du arbeitest mit dem Materialteam zusammen, und Anna, du bereitest die Umfrage vor.
Markus: Klingt gut. Ich werde parallel dazu die Produktionsprozesse nochmals überprüfen und sehen, ob wir da noch Optimierungen vornehmen können.
Kevin: Perfekt. Dann denke ich, sind wir soweit durch. Hat noch jemand etwas?
Anna: Nein, von meiner Seite aus ist alles geklärt.
Thomas: Ebenfalls nichts mehr hinzuzufügen.
Markus: Ich bin auch fertig.
Sandra: Dann würde ich sagen, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Kevin: Gut, danke nochmal an alle. Bis bald!
Anna: Tschüss!
Thomas: Tschüss!
Markus: Tschüss, bis dann!
Sandra: Tschüss!
Kevin: Also, bevor wir schließen, noch ein Punkt. Wir sollten den Fokus auf die kommenden Markteinführungen nicht verlieren. Gibt es da noch offene Themen?
Markus: Ja, tatsächlich. Wir müssen sicherstellen, dass die neuen Modelle rechtzeitig fertig sind. Die letzten Tests haben einige Probleme aufgezeigt.
Sandra: Welche Art von Problemen?
Markus: Hauptsächlich Softwarefehler in den neuen elektronischen Schließmechanismen. Wir arbeiten daran, aber es braucht noch Zeit.
Anna: Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, externe Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen, um das zu beschleunigen?
Markus: Ja, wir haben bereits einige Angebote von Drittanbietern eingeholt. Ich werde die Optionen durchgehen und die beste auswählen.
Thomas: Und was ist mit den Produktionskapazitäten? Sind wir bereit für die höheren Stückzahlen?
Sandra: Ja, die Produktionslinien sind soweit vorbereitet. Wir müssen nur sicherstellen, dass die Lieferketten stabil sind.
Kevin: Gut, dann haben wir alles auf dem Schirm. Gibt es sonst noch etwas Dringendes?
Anna: Nein, das sollte es sein. Danke für die Übersicht, Kevin.
Thomas: Ja, danke. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Markus: Tschüss.
Sandra: Tschüss, bis später.
Kevin: Bis dann. Danke euch allen.